it's beginning of October which means
the Supreme Court is back in session
after it's summer recess we're you know
we're looking at another very exciting
year where the court tackles some of the
most politically divisive issues in
American life and here are three cases
to watch this term really first big
controversial case of this term is is
case out of Texas dealing with the use
of racial preferences or affirmative
action in higher education that's Fisher
reverse University of Texas at Austin
does equal protection under the law of
mean that you treat everyone the same
that essentially the Constitution is
colorblind and that's how equal
protections guaranteed and then on the
other side says that equal protection
requires equality of opportunity and
that requires the government or the
state university in this case to craft
race-conscious measures that take race
into account in order to create a
diversity on campus what Texas is
calling a critical mass of
underrepresented students the second
case worth watching this term is an
Arkansas Game and Fish Commission versus
United States so at issue here is that
the US Army Corps of Engineers as part
of its flood management and maintaining
this dam in southern Missouri flooded
property 23,000 acres of property owned
by this state agency in Arkansas and
caused five-and-a-half million dollars
worth of damage it's largely due to
trees so this has to do with the takings
Clause of the Fifth Amendment which says
that when the government takes a private
property for public use it must pay just
compensation and so this is a you know
subsection of takings clause but it's
quite important and certainly for any
homeowners property owners business
owners whose land could lie within what
could potentially be a floodplain thanks
to the US Army Corps of Engineers the
outcome of this case matters the third
case to keep an eye on is actually it's
actually two cases being heard on the
same day out of Florida dealing with the
use of drug sniffing dogs by law
enforcement that the police used a drug
dog in one case to sniff outside of a
home and then the dog gave its alert and
said you know there's marijuana growing
inside the home and this was done
without a warrant and did the and so the
question is is did police need a warrant
do they need to show probable cause in
order to bring a drug dog to somebody's
house the other case is we having do
with the drugs dog searching a car is
especially interesting
the florida supreme court in that case
got into the issue of how is this dog
trained you know what what assurances do
the courts have these dogs are properly
trained do we know how they behaved in
other situations do they always get the
same allure they do something different
and also the handler is the handler
properly trained and certified how do we
know this what sort of assurances do the
courts have that this dog is not just
doing what the handlers want to do as a
way of getting around a probable cause
requirement so it's going to be very
interesting to see what the Supreme
Court has to say about that because that
that's that would particularly limit law
enforcement use of these sort of animals
in drug cases